Reshooting video 11 solution.
So, previously we found a histogram of the signed errors of using our
guess of 1,451 and a half seconds.
Here we're trying to find a similar histogram, but of the absolute errors.
So, to do that we're going to do something extremely similar.
let's again run through the time until next list.
So, here again we're going to run through the time until next list.
But instead of just depending the signed difference here,
we're going to create a new list, abs_diffs.
And we're going to append the absolute value of the very same difference.
So, let's just go ahead and evaluate that.
Now that we have those values, we can create a histogram.
So, let's just recall what we're looking at, we're looking at each actual
intertweet time and subtracting from it, our guess of 1,451 and a half seconds.
We've collected all of those differences together in a list and
this is the histogram of those differences.
And, let's use describe to get the answers that we want.
You can see here that the mean absolute difference is 4446.8.